I never thought that I would feel this
good mentally I have not
faked happiness this is big for me
probably four months
that's good
because I think that's something that I
unfortunately pass down to you that you
felt like you had to project happiness
all the time oh
I don't feel like it was passed down you
get it by watching me I didn't say hey
this is you yeah yeah yeah you know I
guess so it's why the other day I asked
you how do you see your life like how do
you see yourself yesterday that last
night last night yeah and you were and I
said to answer me on the podcast but how
like when you visualize yourself
do you visualize yourself struggling for
money do you visualize what do you
visualize no I I and do you think about
that stuff all the time I it's usually a
Daydream though like that's what it is
yeah I I daydream all the time I
daydream when I'm playing video games I
daydream when I'm driving which is
dangerous don't do that
um I I daydream
I daydream in the grocery store like I
daydream at all times like just about
and how do you see yourself
living a high life I've never I've never
daydreamed or imagined myself at the
bottom
and I guess for me that's just kind of
always been my goal however like I've
had to go through struggles I've had to
go through with no money but I've always
had a support system which has been
really important so do you still
negative talk yourself
that's such a huge thing dude I won't
allow myself to even think
I don't you know listen calling myself a
piece of [__] or whatever
or used to be you know just part of the
routine and I used to think I should
I used to think that if you talked good
about yourself or well about yourself or
thought
you know this is what I'm gonna have
that it was
conceited and that you need to be more
humble and be self-deprecating but your
brain listens to what you're saying
about yourself yeah well I I don't know
if a lot of the talking bad about myself
is really around anymore I talk about
what I want
like I talk about the podcasts and and
what we're gonna do with it I talk about
going on the road I think the fact that
I'm already talking about different
jokes and talking about [__] with my
girlfriend and what I can do and maybe
something else I can talk about is
already me
listening to those elevated thoughts
about how I just want to go further up
instead of staying I mean look in the
last I'm not even going to say year in
the last six months my life has already
changed yeah that's what matters like
it took a while but things are happening
dude the three words and I forget who I
picked this up from this is not me but
attention intention and discipline
like what are you gonna Focus your
attention on I definitely need more and
put intention behind it you know that I
need more discipline the journal is the
thing that's been helping me by
discipline
because I make sure if I do it every
morning and every night and I've never
been able to stick to something like
that
and even on the road on the nights that
I've forgotten I
forgive myself and I write it in the
journal hey dude it's totally okay
not every no you're never gonna be
perfect and the thing you know what's
really it's really helping me with you
know my biggest thing has always been
and this is the same for everybody for
most people it's comparison
in competition
and I'm not comparing myself to or
competing with anybody besides myself
I'm not comparing myself
and
you know
I
I really am really really am I in other
people's like the general Public's pop
opinion of me has never really affected
me very much no but my peers opinions of
me have right and it's something that
I've worked really hard to
put on the back burner and this has
really helped dude I really feel more
clear and focused at at 53 as an older
gentleman
um
but I I just am so excited about
what's hap what's gonna happen here oh
yeah oh yo yo yeah and as a younger
gentleman I'm also very excited
are you do you consider yourself a
gentleman you are a gentleman actually
what a dick question to ask well no I
don't I don't know I can what I consider
myself a gentleman
was that an accent
no it was just some attitude oh okay
yeah I would consider myself a gentleman
no that I didn't mean that question came
out wrong yeah because I know you are a
gentleman I meant like when you called
me an older gentleman that was a
gentleman in that way you're like a dude
younger dude yeah not younger gentleman
nah because I feel like due to a younger
gentleman have an old soul
you know what I'm saying yeah you're a
younger dude yeah I think so yeah you
know you know gentlemen younger man
it's so weird that you're 26 dude it's
so [__] crazy yep 27 next year yeah I
know how it works just making sure
just don't forget you think I don't I'll
just make you sure